can you do a what I eat in a day so this  morning I had cold ribs from last night  and I'm going to have crunchy things  this evening this is a recipe I came up  with you get pretty creative I guess if  you've only been eating meat for a  number of years you can take any kind of  beef or lamb pressure cook it until you  can shred it into bits and then pour all  those shredded bits into an air fryer  add Tallow and then air fry it with salt  and you get shredded crunchy things that  are just God's greatest gift those kind  of recipes are available for free online  diet.com Jordan Peterson my dad his  average day is like Stripling steak  strip loin steak strip loin steak he's a  lot too he probably eats three and a  half or four pounds of meat a day he's a  beast but I definitely recommend eating  crunchy bits crunchy things  crunchy things is probably a better name  and crunchy things